the rog phone 6 pro yes we got it
extremely early asus is pushing their
limits on the mobile front and so is
black shark with the 5 pro with the
classic inbuilt triggers but are they on
par or will one come up on top who knows
so let's find out
hey y'all it's you with geek culture and
if you're new to the channel what's up
we do tons of stuff here so the next
video might be different from this one
so let's dive in the one thing both
phones have in common is that they both
use an adreno 730 for its gpu but the
key difference is that the rog phone 6
pro
uses a snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 and the
black shock 5 pro uses a snapdragon 8
gen 1. the difference between the
snapdragon 8 plus and the 8 is that the
single cortex x2 core in the snapdragon
8 plus is clocked at up to 3.2 gigahertz
as opposed to the 3.0 gigahertz in the
standard snapdragon 8. also asus sent us
the code 93 game pad and their air
active cooler but to be fair to black
shark we're not gonna be using any of
these another thing to note is that
we'll be playing these games back to
back on the phone's highest performance
settings with blackjack's ludicrous mode
and rog's x mode we're going to be
playing some genshin apex cod m and real
racing 3 on both phones and we're also
going to be running benchmarks with gfx
bench 3dmark and geekbench 5 if you're
into the numbers
so without a further ado let's scheme
so we're going to kick things off with
the rg phone 6 and my gosh you guys
gonna you guys need to see this look at
that
this is beautiful look at the display
but yeah everything's up to the highest
the rog 406 actually has a refresh rate
of 165 hertz so you can expect a lot of
things out of this although it's not
fully utilized but
it is what it is so we'll just get into
it
another cool thing about rog phone is
that you know using game genie you guys
can actually set real-time info at the
bottom or you can just kind of just
shift it any way you want and it
displays the real-time information for
the game such as the fps your phone's
temperature your battery life and the
gpu and cpu load so it's a real nice
touch
it's already monster square for a bit
and the thing is you know a lot of you
have been asking to kind of come here
and just roam around for a bit because
you know it is more graphically
intensive compared to other areas in the
game you know given like the gaming
assets that you use around here and all
the npcs and so far you know there i
haven't noticed any screen tearings as
of yet
the phone is kind of warming up a little
bit it's at 41 degrees right now but you
know it's it's nothing
too much to be worried about but it's
it's fine honestly
yeah
so let's go to an open space and see
how it fares
oh that was quick
animations are really smooth
look at that
that's great
yeah again no screen tearing whatsoever
[Applause]
it just feels so much more fluid
compared to like playing on other phones
that i've had so far
frame rate has only been dropping around
like two frames
three frames ish okay no two or one
frames ish
per second so
so far so good okay so let's go into the
spiral abyss and get into some proper
action
all right that's pretty bad
[Applause]
yeah combat's all fighting great
[Applause]
sorry guys i'm getting a little bit
intense here but the thing is we are on
a roll
right now i think
nice but yeah are you okay after
completing one flaw
this
this is oh okay this is hella smooth
i can't wait to run out the games on it
so let's just move on to
let's see apex legends yeah let's do
that
okay so with apex loaded up um okay
everything's on the highest extreme hd
ultra frame rate you know
no definite smoothing no we don't want
that display fps
everything else is set on on so it's
gonna be quite heavy on the phone
let's just dive into a match
but i also need to say that you know
volume right now it's about let's go
60 75
and it's looking and sounding amazing
and there's one thing i'll give to this
phone is that it's speakers are really
good
i can't even lie this the speakers are
actually really good
why are you so scared
oh okay saw that you saw that yep
frame drop right there
[Music]
attacking great that was really close
okay so other than the firmware dropped
just now that happened while we were
landing
while we were fighting it's been very
smooth
so far
let's just get these guys over here i
see them
someone wandered into our safe space
[Applause]
okay so performance-wise you know it's
still dropping about two frames-ish but
nothing too drastic compared to the
little drop that we had just now while
we were dropping from the air no it's
around 41 degrees for the phone itself
but honestly it doesn't feel it does
feel a bit warm
but you know it's actually quite all
right
yeah it's it's manageable it's not
uncomfortable in any sort of way you're
not gonna be cooking any eggs on it but
you know it's very comfortable but yeah
with that um let's actually move on to
cod mobile okay we have call of duty
loaded up so let's just look at the
settings real quick
same drill everything's on very high max
frame rate
multiplayer is gonna be a death of feel
everything's on so you know you're gonna
get the best experience out of this
thing
so let's just move on and play a game
man it's been a while
but yes you're at 82 for the battery you
know cpu load and gpu load seems to be
doing fine
fps doing pretty fine at 60fps it's only
dropping by like one frame right now but
honestly it's still pretty smooth
nice
[Applause]
so far the game runs really smooth in my
hands
[Applause]
contact with enemy
[Applause]
the framerate isn't dropping by one
every second or so
temperatures at 37 degrees right now
which is honestly nothing compared to
gam chin
or apex
yeah it's honestly feeling really good
right now
and yeah that's that should be for call
mobile it's
it's running ridiculously smooth
okay last one real racing three
okay so we do a racing three boots up
there are no real um sliders or anything
for the graphics but i think all the
assets have been downloaded
so let's just hop into the track and see
how it performs
[Applause]
[Music]
very smooth 45 ps right now
the phone has actually cooled down quite
a bit from just now
it's at 35 degrees right
[Music]
now and gyroscoping this thing is really
smooth and responsive
this honestly would be able to take it
because honestly there isn't much of a
change when it comes to performance or
even the real-time info
frame rate is way above expectations and
after that it's temperatures at 36
degrees it feels really cool at the back
compared to genshin and apex
so yeah with that let's move on to the
black shark
okay so we have the blackshot five pro
down here in genji back in monstat and
let's just see the settings real quick
everything should be on the highest
high high high everything's high okay
cool
60 fps again
but however we're running this thing at
144 hertz so the way we check that is if
we drag the top right top left down and
shark space will pull up here so let's
go to game config
ludicrous mode is on that's the highest
we have down here display wise let's go
to custom
set to 144 hertz
calendar and stuff we're gonna touch
that uh graphic enhancements on high
quality so things were really pushing
the black shock to its limits and the
next thing we need to do is actually
configure the triggers
look at that
sounds great
so go to master config and after that
just assign the bumpers wherever you
want them to activate on
so bb on the attack down here
and then a will be on my sprint
oh yeah so basically the monitoring when
it comes to the black shark it doesn't
show the temperature like the game genie
on the asus but it does show the cpu
frequency and more importantly the frame
rate which is heading at a steady 60 fps
and of course we're back in monster
square again just to see how heavy
or how smooth the phone can run in such
a graphically intense area
and yep a little bit of raindrops here
and there
kind of stuttering here and there but
other than that it's still pretty smooth
i'd say
and to make up for the fact that the
shark space doesn't measure temperature
we're going to be using a temperature
gun again yes of course we can use
developer tools but the thing is i want
to see how each phone handles their
monitoring so let's just check out the
temperature real quick on the back
and
yeah that's oh that's hot yeah it's keep
burning up right now it's
really hot
it's at the most
on gen chin and apex just now was 41
degrees on the asus but this
yeah 43 45 i'm guessing this is where
the chip is
but yeah this thing is heating up
so far it's pretty smooth it's just that
you know you will get a bit of frame
stuttering here and there
let's see how it fares like in combat
there we go
oh okay nevermind
yeah i see that
stuttering a little bit more in combat
[Applause]
[Music]
with combat you guys can see the
stuttering here and there so let's just
move on to something that's more combat
focused let's head on to the abyss
all right
let's just clear the other level one but
this thing is really getting hot this
thing's oh my lord that is
50 45
yeah this thing's honestly
it feels like a microwave here
so let's just see how it fares like in
combat
oh logie
[Music]
[Applause]
obviously the speakers are actually
doing pretty okay
they're rather loud right now
they are about like 80 to 25
but it still sounds good but honestly
still not as good as the asus right now
but yeah okay this thing is getting way
too hot hold on let me just check that
out real quick
yeah it's still bought at like 45 but it
feels it's really hot in the bottom down
here
[Applause]
i mean it's still holding pretty well at
60fps with a bit of frame starting here
and there but other than that
it performs fine but i guess you know if
you want to go on for a long period of
time playing
game chin
maybe try it out
you might want to think twice about that
all right let's just move on to apex
then
all right so we have apex loaded up
let's just see the settings real quick
and
yeah extreme hd ultra frame rate that
the smoothing's off obviously display
fps is on
and everything else is on so let's just
hop into a match i've already set up the
master config for the black shark stuff
as you can see down here
so once for aiming ones for firing so
let's just get into it
and play a game
not too bad
the baseline for the asus was like 41
degrees so
we should be doing good
so far no framework drops like just now
laces
looking very promising right now
actually
[Music]
if i have to go
yep firing with the triggers on feels
like a dream
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah look at that i can i shoot so much
better with the trigger zone like that
[Applause]
even though it didn't take much time for
the phone to heat up just now with
kenshin it doesn't feel
that warm
in the same amount of time i've spent in
apex competition so
hmm
but so far it feels really good we just
got off two gun fights and let's see how
it fares
it's still about 40 okay you went up
like
up one one five one eight around there
just now as i saw it
two degrees is higher than the baseline
41 degrees just now
but yeah see how responsive the triggers
are when you start aiming downsides when
you start firing
it's amazing
and i can't wait to see how it performs
like when it comes to cot later on
so so far uh hardly any frame drops
honestly it feels really good to play
with the triggers
and
let's check temperature wise before we
move on to the next game
yeah about 2 degrees celsius almost
three ish degrees celsius difference
compared to the asus rog just now
so
let's just move on to card
so my settings are graphic quality isn't
high frame rates on high uh we're gonna
play multiplayer so let's just turn all
that on
and then restart the game so that
everything can take effect
okay so now that everything is properly
set up let's just jump into a match
enemy contact
okay let's just do this targets in sight
so 90 fps no screen tearing whatsoever
so far
[Applause]
feels really good enemy contact
[Applause]
feels very good in fact
oh enemies
there we go
honestly it does
feel like i'm cheating with these added
triggers on top i mean like everyone
else can get external controllers yes
but the thing is having it on there is
such
it's so convenient it's great
so yeah no screen tearing nothing much
let's just check temperature real quick
i think
with cod the black shark is handling
pretty well
i see that look it's like 33.9 it's not
that bad because it's called ut i mean
compared to apex and kenshin this is
honestly one of the least intensive when
it comes to
the gpu and the cpu load so
it's great
now that's more of the real racing
okay so we're in real racing right now
and you download all the assets
obviously there are no sliders just like
in the rog phone 6 so let's just get
into a race
all right just at rg 0.6 we're going to
be playing gyro
[Music]
very responsive
[Applause]
[Music]
60 fps right now no screen time
whatsoever and the game looks really
good the models on the f1 car also looks
great and this is honestly the least
intensive of all the games that we
played today and it's still holding up
itself
yeah a little bump in temperature yeah
but honestly
still all right compared again chin and
apex
so with that let's move on to the
benchmarks
for 3d mark the best loop scores are
2413 for the rog and 2572 for the black
shark geekbench scores for the rog are 1
303 for single core and 2999 for
multi-core and the black shark scores
are one two one one for single core and
3446 for multi-core for gfx bench using
the aztec ruins high tier test as a
basis the rog phone 6 pro went up to 45
fps and the blackshot 5 pro performed at
57 fps
having done with both phones obviously
the asus wins out on heat management but
the black shark especially with his
inbuilt triggers felt like a dream and i
always felt like i was cheating because
of how responsive the controls are and
talk about how easy it is to set it up
on the benchmark front make what you
will out of the scores but the black
sharks seemed to handle gfx and 3dmark
pretty well it even ran four to five
frames per second higher than rog with
the gfx test i recorded the temperatures
again and it just confirms that asus
really has it going with its heat
management our game cool 6 cooling
system however the blackshot 3d mark
test smoother compared to the rog 4 and
6 pro even though the black shark got
beat out on the single core score
compared to rog phone 6 pro it knocked
everything out of the park with this
multi-core score so the question remains
would you want a good looking phone with
great heat management or a phone that
has great inbound triggers and
processing capabilities i'll leave that
up for you to decide so if you have any
questions leave them in the comment
section down below and i'll do my best
to get to them and if you like this
video don't forget to follow us on all
of our socials leave a like and
subscribe to us we have a ton of videos
coming your way this is ineo and i'm
going to go play these
[Music]